hey everyone its Johanna here I'm so
excited to share with you my quick and
easy lunch to go ideas which is under
300 calories so if you're struggling to
find the time to cook all you're
struggling to eat healthy when you're
out and about these recipes are for you
all of the ingredients I've chosen
either does not need to be cooked or
they can be bought ready from your local
supermarket therefore it literally takes
5 minutes to prep them up it's quick its
lunch in portion it's low in calories
you will be watching your waistline at
the same time you will be dropping the
pounds so let's start with the first
recipe my first line is a grab-and-go
prawn pizza pockets it's really
convenient because you can eat it
wherever you are and I've chosen pizza
because pizza is much low in calories in
comparison to bread or wraps this
literally takes 5 minutes to prepare
it's really creamy and it has the carbs
protein healthy fat and vegetables you
need the ingredients you'll need are 1
whole-wheat pita bread about 85 grams of
cooked prawn that's about 7 large prawn
1 medium tomato 1/8 of an avocado 1
large tablespoon of low-fat Greek yogurt
and just one teaspoon of lemon for the
extra zing so all I want to do with
these ingredients except the tomato is
to mix them up and the yogurt is
providing you with a creamy texture once
it's done what I want to do now is to
stop my tomatoes into my pita pockets
and to add my creamy ingredients into my
pita pockets as well and it's done what
we want to do now is to wrap this up in
a kitchen foil put it into our container
and bring it up a lunch they have it's
my really quick and creamy prawn pita
pockets these two pizza pockets only
contained two hundred and ninety six
point five calories it's really creamy
and
much low in calories compared to the one
you buy in supermarkets so make it
yourself if you're planning to go on a
low carb and high-protein diet which
will help you to lose weight try my
spicy grilled chicken salad topped with
goats cheese you're getting your low
carb and low calories from the variety
of vegetables you're getting your lean
protein from your grilled chicken and
also your healthy fats and protein from
your goats cheese do you know that
lettuce is considered a free food
because of the low calorie content so
feel free to help yourself to as much
lettuce as you want the ingredients
you'll need to make this protein packet
salad are 100 gram of grilled chicken
about 50 gram of lettuce 1 medium tomato
sliced 1 small slice of goat's cheese
which is about 15 grams 1 tablespoon of
mixed seeds 1 tbsp of your favorite did
I like spice therefore I'm going for my
hot salsa day and just 1 teaspoon of
lemon for the extra zing just place half
of your letters into your lunch box with
the remaining letters add your sliced
tomatoes 1 tbsp of mixed seeds 1
tablespoon of your favorite dip half of
your grilled chicken breast and just mix
it up don't forget to drizzle it with a
little bit of lemon add your mix
ingredients into your lunch box all
you'll need to do now is to top it up
with your goat's cheese and the
remaining chicken breast so this is your
low carb high protein salad this large
bowl only contains two hundred and
ninety seven point five calories and
trust me it will fill you up again it
takes less than five minutes to prepare
because all you're doing is mixing all
the ingredients up and it's ready to go
so there is no reason No
to eat healthy if you're someone who
must have your rice in your meal why
don't you try couscous as an alternative
40 gram of uncooked rice contain about
130 calories and 40 gram of uncook
couscous has about 90 calories so try
couscous for a lower calorie option that
leads on to my next recipe which is my
rainbow couscous salad which is also
suitable for vegan this salad is packed
full of beans and full of protein and it
was satisfy those of you who likes your
rice so the ingredients you'll need are
40 grams of uncooked whole wheat
couscous which will be about 1 small
bowl when it's cooked 1 medium tomato
sliced quarter can of red beans which is
about 60 gram quarter can of chickpeas
which is also about 60 gram 50 gram of
sweet corns and piece and just a little
bit of lemon for the taste so what we
need to do to make this rainbow salad is
to choose colorful ingredients I've used
frozen peas and corns so allow them to
thaw
I've gently heated up my red beans and
my chickpeas I've cooked my couscous
with a ratio of 2 to 1 so what we need
to do now is to mix all the ingredients
up and just add a little bit of lemon if
you like raw onions or raw garlic you
can always add them in and just add a
little bit of black pepper and salt to
taste and there you have it my rainbow
couscous salad which is a great
alternative to rice you're getting your
carbs from the couscous and your healthy
fat and protein from the beans as well
as your vegetables this is so quick to
make and it only contains 200 83.5
calories it's a much healthier option
much lower in calories in comparison to
your Asian fried rice there you have it
this are my low calories lunch
alternatives which will help you to lose
weight don't forget that you can get all
these recipes from our website at
Johanna SOCOM please follow me on
Facebook and Instagram because that's
where I'll do myself daily and for me to
connect with you and do like this video
share this video and please subscribe to
my youtube channel for more fitness and
nutritional videos